>> Greg: REMEMBER BETO?
YESTERDAY HE SAID EARTH ONLY HAS
TEN YEARS LEFT WITH NO ACTION IS
TAKEN ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO WORK IN THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY, THOSE WHO ARE,
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY ARE BROUGHT
ALONG AS PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MAKE THIS TRANSITION AND
THEN TEN YEARS THAT WE HAVE LEFT
TO US, AS THE SCIENTISTS TELL
US.
>> Greg: NOW IT'S TEN YEARS.
TO SAVE HUMANITY, HE PROPOSES
SPENDING 5 TRILLION OVER THREE
DECADES.
I DON'T GET IT.
THIS BEGS THE QUESTION WHY.
I THINK HE SAW AOC CLAIM WE ONLY
HAD 12 YEARS LEFT AND HE THOUGHT
OH, YEAH?
I CAN DO IT IN TEN.
IT'S LIKE A HYSTERICAL VERSION
OF "NAME THAT TUNE" MINUS THE
TUNES, JUST THE LOONS.
WHY THE RETURN TO GLOBAL SCARE
TACTICS?
I BLAME TRUMP.
AMERICA'S ECONOMY IS BOOMING,
UNEMPLOYED FOR EVERYONE IS AT A
HISTORIC LOW.
MANUFACTURING JOBS RETURNED BY
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WORKING OUT WHO
NEVER WORKED A DAY IN THEIR
LIVES.
LOOK AT JESSE.
[LAUGHTER]
APOCALYPSE TRUMP NO LONGER
WORKS.
WE ARE BACK TO CHICKEN LITTLE
THEATER.
THIS WON'T STOP BETO FROM USING
JETS, TRAINS, OR AUTOMOBILES.
RATIONING IS FOR THE LITTLE
PEOPLE BUT NOT FOR HIM.
JUST A MONTH AGO HE WAS THE
MEDIA'S BFF, EARNEST PLATITUDES
PROPPED UP BY WEALTH THAT MASKED
DECADES OF FAILURES.
TO VANITY FAIR, HE WAS KING.
TO THE REST OF US, HE REMINDED
US OF THE ROOMMATE HIGH ON NO
DOZE WHO LECTURES EVERYONE, A
MOTIVATIONAL SPEAKER IN SEARCH
OF AN AUDIENCE.
MAYOR PETE IS SMARTER, PLUS HE
CAN SPEAK WITHOUT INFLICTING
COLLATERAL DAMAGE ON BYSTANDERS.
[EXHALES]
I'M DONE.
DAGEN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HIS
PLAN?
>> Dagen: THE WHOLE THING
DOESN'T WORK.
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY
ARE GOING TO PAY $5, $6, $7 FOR
GASOLINE.
REDUCED POWER PLANT EMISSIONS BY
30% SINCE 2005 BECAUSE OF
PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE WERE DISCOVERING MORE
AND MORE NATURAL GAS.
PRICES ARE COLLAPSING.
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY HAS CREATED
MILLIONS OF JOBS BUT I'M GOING
TO WIPE ALL THAT AWAY FOR A
CAMPAIGN SLOGAN.
GOOD LUCK ON THAT.
THIS IS A SIGN OF DESPERATION,
SO ERIC SWALWELL WILL CLEARLY
WANT TO BE CORNERING THAT VOTE.
MAYOR PETE AND HIS HUSBAND AND
HIS TWO DOGS, VERY AUTHENTIC,
VERY CHARMING, THE FAMILY.
HE DOESN'T LOOK ENOUGH LIKE A
KENNEDY TO GET THAT VOTING BLOCK
TO CARE.
SO HE'S DONE.
>> Greg: HE HAS HALF A
KENNEDY.
I THINK BETO HOOKED HIS WAGON TO
AOC.
>> Jesse: I WOULD NOT HITCH MY
WAGON TO AOC.
>> Dana: SHE SAID HIS PLAN WAS
NOT BOLD ENOUGH.
THERE YOU GO.
>> Jesse: HEAR WHAT I WOULD
SAY, GREG.
I AM STILL SMARTING FROM THE
COMMENTARY.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
IF SOMEONE CALLS YOU ON THE
PHONE AND SAYS YOU'RE GOING TO
DIE IN TEN YEARS UNLESS YOU GIVE
ME ALL YOUR MONEY, THAT'S A
SCAM.
HE IS A SCAM ARTIST, AND
EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
BEFORE I RAKE HIM OVER THE
COALS, I WANT TO GIVE SOME
FACTS.
I BROUGHT CHARTS.
>> Dana: I LOVE CHARTS.
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGN
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGA
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGP
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGO
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGR
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGA
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGE
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGI
>> Jesse: >> Greg: DAGN
MY CHARTS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE THEM TO JUAN.
AMERICA REDUCING CO2 EMISSIONS.
LOOK AT CHINA AND THE EE YOU AND
INDIA.
THEY ARE EMITTING LIKE CRAZY.
GREEN NEW DEAL, IN ORDER TO GET
THAT DONE YOU HAVE TO SET ASIDE
THE LANDMASS OF CALIFORNIA TO
HOUSE THE WINDMILLS AND SOLAR
PANELS.
HOW DID WE GET OUT OF THE LAST
ICE AGE IF THERE IS NO FOSSIL
FUELS?
I WONDER HOW THE EARTH HEATED UP
THEN.
WE CAN'T EVEN PREDICT THE
WEATHER NEXT WEEKEND.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO PREDICT WHAT
IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE IN TEN
YEARS?
LET'S THINK ABOUT HOW COCKY BETO
O'ROURKE IS.
>> Greg: WAIT, YOU ARE CALLING
SOMEBODY COCKY?
>> Jesse: I HAVE GROUNDS TO DO
THAT.
YOU HAVE THE U.S. ECONOMY, THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY RUNS THE
ECONOMY AND HAS CRATED ALL THIS
WEALTH, REVOLUTIONIZED
TRANSPORTATION, COMMUNICATIONS,
LIFTED PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY.
BETO, WHO HAS DONE NOTHING
EXCEPT LOSE TO TED CRUZ, COMES
UP AND SAYS I'M GOING TO TAKE
$5 TRILLION AND I'M GOING TO
REVERSE EVERYTHING IN TEN YEARS
AND CHANGE AT ALL.
HE IS NO EINSTEIN.
NO CARNEGIE.
WHERE DOES HE GET OFF THINKING
HE'S GOING TO STOP HUMAN
PROGRESS, PUMP THE BRAKES,
BECAUSE THE REAL REASON HE'S
DOING THIS, HE FEELS GUILTY OF
THE SUCCESS OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY HAS HAD, BECAUSE HE AND
OTHER LIBERALS HAVE NOT HAD
ENOUGH INPUT IN IT.
>> Greg: JUAN, HOW IS HE GOING
TO GO ON ANOTHER SOUL-SEARCHING
TOUR WITHOUT FOSSIL FUELS?
>> Juan: I THINK WE HAVE --
EVERYONE CAN GO ANYWHERE THEY
WANT TO GO.
I THINK THE NEWS HERE IS YOU'VE
GOT A 80 PLUS PERCENT OF
DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT THIS IS
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
>> Jesse: THINGS MUST BE GOOD
IF THAT'S THE NUMBER-ONE ISSUE.
>> Juan: IN SOME PLACES, YOU
SAY IT WAS HEALTH CARE OR
EDUCATION.
NOW TODAY 81% SAYING THAT THIS
IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
I ARGUE WITH JESSE, WITH DAGEN
AND THESE GUYS ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THAT NEVER CHANGES
ANYTHING EXCEPT THAT IT GETS ME
HEATED.
LET'S NOT ARGUE ABOUT IT BUT WE
CAN ARGUE ABOUT THE FACT THAT
DEMOCRATS THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
IT'S NOT JUST BETO AND IT'S NOT
JUST AOC.
YOU HAVE A CLEAR MAJORITY, SUPER
MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS TO SAY
THIS IS OUR NUMBER ONE ISSUE,
AND YOU HAVE POLITICIANS IN A
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT SAYING
WE ARE GOING TO SPEAK TO YOUR
ISSUE, VOTERS.
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
REPUBLICANS AREN'T SPEAKING TO
CLIMATE CHANGE, WHICH IS WHAT
OPENS THE DOOR FOR THESE KIND OF
PROPOSALS.
>> Greg: I THINK JUAN IS RIGHT
IN THE SENSE THAT WE COULD --
I'M GOING TO SAY WE BUT I'M NOT
A DEMOCRAT.
SPEAKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE,
TALKING ABOUT NUCLEAR POWER.
SOLAR AND WIND ARE SO DELUDED.
ENVIRONMENTALLY, TERRIBLE FOR
THE PLANET.
>> Dana: YOU CAN'T STORE IT.
THEY ARE WORKING ON IT.
IN THE PREVIOUS POLLS WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKED, DO YOU
LIKE THE IDEA OF MEDICARE FOR
ALL, PEOPLE SAY YEAH, I LIKE
THAT.
DO YOU LIKE MEDICARE FOR ALL IF
THAT MEANS IT'S GOING TO COST X
NO, I DON'T LIKE THAT.
IN THIS POLL, I WOULD'VE LIKED
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO BE ASKED IF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS YOUR NUMBER
ONE ISSUE, IF I ASKED YOU WERE
GOING TO SOLVE THAT BY UTILIZING
NUCLEAR POWER, DO YOU SUPPORT
THAT?
WHAT WITH THE NUMBER BE?
PROBABLY BECAUSE OF
MISINFORMATION AND UNEDUCATED
PEOPLE ABOUT NUCLEAR POWER, IT
WOULD PROBABLY DOWN AROUND 40%.
WHEN THAT IS ACTUALLY THE ONLY
TRUE WAY THAT YOU GET ALL THOSE
OTHER COUNTRIES TO REDUCE THEIR
EMISSIONS.
>> Greg: NUCLEAR POWER HAS
COME A LONG WAY.
FEWER MELTDOWNS.
GEN 4 NUCLEAR REACTORS ARE
BETTER.
AND THEY FEED OFF THEIR OWN WAYS
WHICH IS GOOD.
>> Jesse: REPUBLICANS IN ORDER
TO GET IN ON THE OPENING, THEY
SHOULD GO FOR CONVERSATION.
TEDDY ROOSEVELT, LOT OF THE
WESTERN GOVERNORS ARE
REPUBLICAN, CONSERVATIONISTS.
THEY LOVE FISHING, HUNTING,
DON JR. IS A BIG OUTDOORSMAN.
HE CAN SELL THAT IN A HEARTBEAT.
MUCH MORE APPEALING.